john quando seu olhar muda o mundo muda
eu acredito que a forma com que a gente
vê a realidade se transforma no jeito
que a gente vive esse cara aqui se
conhece cara aqui esse cara aí ó depois
de 20 anos ouvindo que a natureza tinha
pra ensinar se transformou neste caso
aqui e aí em gratidão a tudo o que a
natureza tem me ensinado
eu queria ofertar uma oração ao mar
compartilhar ela com vocês
[Música]
a superfície da água e leva
as profundezas do oceano o envolve
à minha volta eu sinto corais areia e
pedras
uma vasta imensidão e respira me
inspirando e inspirando dentro do pulmão
líquido da terra
[Música]
eu reverencio ao teu sábio e infinito
poder
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o vaivém vitimado das correntes eu danço
eu me equilibro eu me posiciono
[Música]
[Aplausos]
em um movimento única eu me impulsiona e
a onda me desliza sem esforço
[Música]
eu confio e me entrego ao turbilhão da
sua espuma liquide ficante
sinto sua morte e renascimento em mim
[Música]
volto ao ponto onde tudo começou
sou mesmo é diferente
ao mesmo tempo a cada onda gira em torno
de mim mesmo me aproximando um pouco
mais de quem eu sou eu ea onda
somos um eu eo oceano
somos um
[Música]
inspirar novas formas de ver e viver em
harmonia com a natureza inspirar pessoas
empresas e organizações a surfar a onda
da sua própria vida
esse é o meu propósito quando eu inspiro
é o pulmão da terra que me inspira
quando eu spiro é o pulmão da terra que
me inspira a respiração é o movimento
básico da vida expansão pausa contração
pausa a inspiração é o movimento básico
do universo da mesma forma como a
natureza funciona que o oceano funciona
a gente funciona
eu sou do rio de janeiro
e quando eu era pequeno na barriga da
minha mãe meu pai pilotando o barco a
primeira linha
eu senti a força da água dentro de mim
todos nós sentimos quando a gente é
criança a gente sabe que a gente vai
fazer aqui
só que a gente vai esquecendo quando
brincava de pegar jacaré pequenininho
na beira da praia eu sentia a força do
mar dentro de mim todos nós sentimos aos
12 anos me tornei a trata de pólo
aquático que me ensinou a qual a cidade
se mover na água como um peixe com o
máximo de resultado mínimo de esforço
depois aos 17 anos
as correntes me levaram para outros
mares má administração
e essa frase me marcou muito
logo no início onde meus talentos e
paixões encontram as necessidades do
mundo
lá está meu caminho meu lugar e aí eu
fui inundado por tendências de vanguarda
teorias modernas da administração
me apaixonei pelo propósito de ser um
agente de mudança
eu me engajei em projetos sociais
movimentos sociais fez estágios em
empresas de excelência
aprendi empreende nunca teve carteira
assinada
só que alguma coisa estava errada minha
vida dentro em desequilíbrio eu queria
mudar o mundo em sete dias e eu ouvi um
chamado do mar e um chamado no caminho
de ser consultor cuida de você volta a
fazer o esporte a respirar natureza vai
trabalhar com desenvolvimento
organizacional desenvolvimento humano
liderança cultura a propósito
sustentabilidade muito interessante
também faz parte de mim então eu decidi
abraçar esses dois caminhos
ao invés de sair do rio para são paulo
eu vim pra cá pra floripa
ele me abraçou a ele é que escolhe a
gente ia para são paulo para outros
lugares
trabalhando remotamente e descobri que
com três dias de workshop por mês eu
conseguia pagar as contas
neste momento minha vida começou a se
equilibrar no movimento entre ilhas
remotas e grandes centros
porque eu tive uma grande idéia um
princípio falava pra mim quanto menor o
custo fixo mensal maior a sua liberdade
quanto menor o seu custo fixo mensal
maior a sua liberdade
então vendi meu carro e fui pro avaí só
que eu perdi um jeito diferente
comprava uma van com pavan tira os
bancos montanha casinha e ficou a dois
meses
e quando depois da primeira vez eu fiz
isso por 12 vezes dois meses por ano e
continuar fazendo é um encontro com a
simplicidade origem
e aí eu comecei a treinar o bari sul fez
ondas grandes de lá voltei a ser atleta
e me tornei uma referência no esporte
internacional
a minha conexão com o mar voltou a
paixão pela cultura baiana acendeu e
2005 quando eu voltei falei
será que jovens de baixa renda não
poderiam ter jornadas no mar e aprender
sobre a vida sua fauna da sua vida e
assim foi
centenas de jovens durou sete anos e na
verdade eu bati muito cabeça no início
trabalhar com o adolescente né
não é fácil mas eles que ensinaram me
ensinaram um método que virou hoje meta
do peixe onde depois de um certo tempo
como os pássaros eu fui migrando para
outra ilha fernando de noronha que
também me abraçou e comecei a trabalhar
com alto conhecimento através da água
um amigo meu me batizou essa profissão
de cicote quando a gente treina o nosso
olhar a gente já aprendi a observar os
movimentos da vida não sobre como é
observar a vida não do ponto de vista do
nosso julgamento mas sim a partir da
consciência que existe ali
a natureza é um segredo aberto e aí que
cursos em noronha até medo devido às
famílias empresas começaram a crescer
trabalho com alto conhecimento com
contemplação e com performance que me
ajudou a me sentir adolescente até hoje
o outro caminho de consultor facilitador
também continua a crescer
se você já não está no mesmo lugar a
gente tem uma ilusão de que aquele
trabalho não vai frutificar vai
é só você manter essa conexão em rede e
aí eu pude dar consultoria pra empresas
dos mais diversos portes setores fundar
programa desenvolvimento o processo de
mudanças
pura startup de inovação que sempre foi
a minha grande paixão negócios sociais e
kehl que o ato mais forte até hoje
inclusive meus clientes de consultoria
agora a maioria deles tem alguma coisa a
ver com a preservação com uma grande
presente da vida a e aí o programa
emerge o impulso emerge a partir da
observação da natureza ajuda a gente
olhar para quem a gente é olhar pra foi
o que está emergindo do futuro e pra que
a gente consiga se posicionar para
também surfar a onda da vida dentro e
fora d'água
e aí de repente eu recebi um convite que
me deu esse apelido homem peixe o peixe
um canal de televisão a cabo a tv a cabo
falou poxa é esse a gente acompanhar se
algumas dessas suas jornadas pelas ilhas
do mundo como é que seria essa história
do surfe de corpo sem prancha resgate de
origem e eu queria contar duas histórias
pra vocês de duas jornadas que acho que
é simbolizam os grandes aprendizados
desses últimos tempos
a primeira é a rocco lê que essa canoa
feita com pedaços de madeira amarras sem
nenhum parafuso nos moldes das canoas
ancestrais havaianas um conhecimento que
está vestindo por mais de 300 anos
só que a canoa ela representa muito mais
é um símbolo de um resgate da identidade
do povo avaiana o povo nova avaiano se
considera se povo avaiano se considera
navegador e considera que a polinésia o
maior país do mundo um país de água
então você precisa transitar e na última
missão é de volta ao mundo a primeira
vez que a canoa deu a volta ao mundo a o
nome da missão é uma lama ro lua cuidar
do planeta ilha mostrando que a micro
sociedade que existe dentro da canoa é a
mesma coisa em um bairro no país no
próprio planeta o que acontece na canoa
acontece no planeta o planeta é uma ilha
então não existe jogar fora a gente
joga dentro e eu aprendi três grandes
valores
eles chegaram em noronha eu recebi foi
convidado e fiz uma jornada de dois dias
e duas noites com eles
só com navegação pelas estrelas sem os
instrumentos tecnológicos com toda a
sabedoria da havaiana na convivência e
os três valores que eu aprendi três
palavras da cultura
a primeira o aloha que significa a o
sopro da vida e reconheça em você
o sopro da vida a segunda o hana família
mas o ano pra eles não é só o laço de
sangue
quem está em volta de você a natureza o
planeta e o cosmos é ohana e quando você
cuida de rana ela cuida de você
o terceiro cocoa que era minha
interpretação é antes de ir em busca das
minhas necessidades individuais
eu tenho certeza de quem está em volta
está com as suas necessidades supridas
acho que como nós como brasileiros
podemos aprender muito sobre isso e aí
depois uma outra história mais radical
que é o banrisul em alta velocidade
tocou embora isso ser puxado no jet ski
todo surfista de peito de corpo tem esse
sonho de ter mais velocidade subir e
descer entre a maior conexão com o mar
então nos últimos dois anos eu tenho
desenvolvido um equipamento uma roupa
torpedo do sul para ser puxado pelo jet
ski em surfar ondas grandes e aconteceu
uma coisa uma onda grande nova chama
johns era um grande desafio eu tinha
duas mães para surfar aquela onda na
primeira manhã
as condições estavam as mais diversas
possíveis
o mar revolto vento não dava pra ver na
hora de puxar quebrou uma parte do
equipamento já esquina e de repente
nessa conversa com o meu oceano interior
eu comecei a escutar algumas perguntas
por que sei fazer isso aqui porque quer
fazer isso quem você acha que você é
qual é a intenção que está por trás
disso
o propósito é esse no final do dia eu
dormir quebrado né cansado com todo o
treino
fiquei com isso na cabeça de manhã ele é
hoje vamos ver o que vai acontecer antes
de amanhecer fomos lá para a onda de
joelson o mar estava liso as condições
perfeitas e de repente o sol nascendo
com a lua do outro lado e observei os
dois astros que tem consciência tem vida
e me veio a seguinte frase eles estão
ali também uma atitude e sacrifício
eles não reclamam a gente se põe em
relação ao sol
a gente nasce em relação ao só eles
sustentam a experiência da vida eles
sustentam a experiência da liberdade e
quando me veio esse profundo se profundo
sentimento de gratidão ver a onda
perfeita
eu estava no lugar certo e deslizar em
alta velocidade e uma era mas nesse
momento
depois de alguns dias
refletindo sobre isso era como se o mar
também apontasse o dedo pra mim e eu de
repente tive um grande site sobre o que
eu aprendi com essa experiência eu
aprendi sobre fé fé pra mim a caminhar
no escuro com firmeza
tenho certeza que uma força maior guia
nossos passos
se você tem um chamado às vezes você não
sabe por que vai depois você vai
entender e todo mundo hoje fala do
estado de flow me ver esse outro insight
minha vida é mais tão importante eu faço
eu amo faço eu tenho talento faz com
valores com propósito eu preciso entrar
num estado de ouvir flow de transbordar
para que o propósito maior possa
acontecer ea partir disso eu fui chamado
para ser embaixador
cinco organizações de preservação
desenvolvimento social nacionais e
internacionais
minha vida cada vez mais tem sido
voltado pra isso não paramos de fazer o
que eu fazia trabalhos no mar os
trabalhos no mar de gente nas grandes
cidades mas buscando trazer toda essa
mensagem que otegi também traz aqui só
quando a gente cuida do planeta é que
ele vai cuidar da gente
meu próximo desafio vai ser uma de
nazaré e aí ficavam falando pra mim não
há sessão onde vai morrer tiveram tempo
premonição de viver paraplégico e eu me
dei conta não é a questão da maior onda
de ser o número 1 em seu carro nunca foi
isso que eu quero me integrar mais eu
quero que meu novo equipamento é mais
velocidade que consiga fazer essa onda
com beleza tirar um tubo sentiu sopro do
mar no meu ouvido
mais uma vez em um lugar que não conheço
bom eu queria convidar todo mundo ficar
de pé
vamos ver é um desafio será que a gente
consegue trazer um pouco o oceano pra cá
então eu queria que intuitivamente cada
um pode até balançar um pouquinho
sentindo aí né
vamos nos desviar e afirmar isso emite
um som em relação marra a onda espumas
ao vento
no fundo todos nós somos artistas ea
nossa maior obra de arte é a nossa
própria vida
obrigado
[Aplausos]